now civilians are fleeing northern Syria
as Turkish troops advance in Kurdish
controlled air areas the offensive was
made possible by the withdrawal of US
troops it's opened a new front in
Syria's eight-year old war so who are
the key players in this particular
conflict and what are their goals let's
begin with Turkey Ankara wants to
establish a so-called safe zone along
its border stretching about 30
kilometers into Syrian territory this
area is currently controlled by Kurdish
militias Turkey wants to clear it out of
Kurds then resettle some 2 million
Syrian refugees there who are currently
living in Turkey then there are the
Syrian Kurds groups like the Kurdish
people's protection units or YPG who
want autonomy the latter fought
alongside the US and turkey against the
so-called Islamic state but Ankara is
offensive could now force Kurdish
militias to throw in their lot with the
Syrian government and its Russian and
Iranian allies and then there is the
u.s. the main goal for the United States
and its allies was to defeat Islamist
forces in Syria like is Washington says
is has now been defeated and has started
withdrawing its troops from northern
East Syria clearing the way for the
Turkish offensive artillery and aerial
bombing light up the sky as Turkish
troops continue their offensive in
Northeast Syria
they're enacting turkeys plan to carve
out a buffer zone along the border and
to move against their longtime enemy the
Kurdish led Syrian democratic forces the
Kurds say several civilians and soldiers
have already died in the assault and
they claimed Turkish bombs are struck a
prison holding fighters from the
so-called Islamic state retaliatory
strikes came from within Syria some
hitting homes on the Turkish side of the
border turkish President Recep Tayyip
erawan oversaw the start of what he
calls Operation peace spring it's an
offensive made possible by Washington's
decision to clear the way by withdrawing
US troops we were put into this battle
interjected it was supposed to be a 30 a
30 day period and we've been there for
many many years and it's time to get out
we're speaking to both sides we've told
President Erdogan how we feel but we are
speaking to both sides and we're seeing
what can be made out of a situation both
the US and Turkey belong to NATO
it's urging caution I count on Turkey to
act with restraint ensure that any
action it may take in northern Syria is
proportionate and measured
we must not jeopardize the gains we have
made together against our common enemy
Isis but the residents of Northeast
Syria aren't counting on words to save
them they're escaping the border towns
by any means possible for some it's only
been a few years since they fled from
the advance of is now they're back on
the road with no clear destination for
war on this Christian Hanul joins me in
studio he's a Middle East expert at the
battles when a film here in Berlin
welcome CW thanks for being with me so
so turkey says it effectively wants to
create a safe zone in Syria where it can
relocate some 2 million Syrian refugees
currently in Turkey just how viable is
look there are there are in in the
regional policy of turkey two major
objectives by this this military
invasion is is putting put forward one
is to avoid that any form of Kurdish
autonomy is created in close to the
borders of Turkey because in the
southeast of Turkey most of the people
that are living there have coded routes
secondly everyone wants to play a major
role in the whole resettlement of Syria
and wants to show military strength in
the region Russia for example Iran and
and the other regional players okay so
let's let's look at what this offensive
will do we have for example Kurdish
forces in northeastern Syria yeah
holding what is Isis that it's locked up
what then happens to them they you know
the turkey is holding in the whole
northern part of Syria also so-called
Sunni Arab regions in in in the area of
Eid Lib then they have already captured
Kurdish areas around a Vareen and now
this is the third invasion into the
north and eastern part which is mainly
Kurdish populated here the Kurdish
militias have detained more than 12,000
suspected is fighters and their families
in so-called seven prisons and camps
this is a big uncertainty Christine
nobody knows what's going to happen with
them if they could can flee or if if a
reshape of the is terrorism can raise
again the problem is that that this
invasion in this respect creates a lot
of uncertainties visa vie vis fighters
and their families on the one hand but
also refugees in the total on the other
because the main objective of other one
in this invasion is to reshuffle the
democracy of the region that means to
settle Sunni Arabs which are already
refugees in southeastern Turkey in a
quarter of populated area in
northeastern Syria okay so the EU has
come out criticizing Turkey in fact
we've we've we've heard voices
cautioning restraint but how much sway
does the EU have here the
has launched this morning a joint
declaration which is criticizing harshly
the Turkish invasion saying it's
creating a lot of uncertainties and
instability is already in Syria and in
the region were so volatile there is no
talk about sanctions or other practical
measures against Turkey we need to know
the EU and Turkey is a very fragile
relationship on the one hand turkey is
member of NATO Turkey is a session
candidate of the EU turkey needs the EU
very much turkey turkey and the other
one is now in a very heavy financial
economic crisis there's a lot of
inflation a lot of criticism the power
is shifting away from elder ones party
so he's an big concern and he tries to
mobilize now all national and military
forces to show strength in order to push
away the attention from the social
economic situation to a more national
thing where he can count on more support
within the population all right
interesting dynamics there Christian her
nails from the battles managed often
here in Berlin thank you it was a
pleasure